okay so the entire news cycle since
monday has been dominated by the slab
heard around the world feels like
everyone on the internet right now is
this guy what up y'all it's your boy
cliff coming at you live on the bus i
actually did take a little bit of
martial arts as a youth so i'm going to
try and grade this fight as we're going
as i'm sure you all know will smith got
on stage during the oscars and hit chris
rock after he dropped a joke in which he
said will's wife jada was gonna be in gi
jain too
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see it all right
[Applause]
it's the most talked about thing on the
internet this week and smith has come
out since the event and he's given a
full apology initially he did talk about
things during his best actor acceptance
speech but this was viewed by many as
being insincere as he didn't apologize
to rock and he also brought up god in
the devil rather than taking full
responsibility himself
denzel said to me a few minutes ago he
said at your highest moment be careful
that's when the devil comes for you
there's been a lot of controversy around
the event with many even saying it's
staged but i really don't think that it
is this is because of a number of
reasons and things like this would need
to be insured pre-packaged and properly
cleared before they happen you also have
to ask what either one of them would get
out of this and though the oscars might
have paid them they'd basically be
accepting money to ruin their
reputations you have to think about
whether the oscars would even be willing
to put forward money for it as it makes
them look really bad as well due to
their lack of security it says a lot
when someone can just walk up on stage
during the event and hit one of the
hosts then not get escort outside and i
don't think that anyone would benefit
from this being staged rock has been
criticized for making distasteful jokes
the oscars for their lack of care around
the entire thing and smithers had his
best actor award over shadowed by it
just think about it like this if you're
an actor in movies then a best actor
award at the oscars is the highest
accolade that you can get there's
absolutely nothing above that and
there's no way for me that smith would
want to take away from the limelight of
that by doing something like this in a
staged position there's also all the
memes that have come out and yet if the
guy is doing a pr stunt then he'd
probably want to do one that makes him
look good since then smith has posted a
full apology on instagram and throughout
this video we're gonna be going over it
giving our thoughts and also discussing
the possible outcomes of the situation
now if you agree with smith's apology
then please hit the thumbs up button and
if you disagree then the dislike's there
for you also if you're going to drop a
comment then please keep it civil and
make sure you respect other people's
opinions just in the same way that you
want yours respected without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the full breakdown now the post
begins by saying violence in all its
forms is poisonous and destructive my
behavior at last night's academy awards
was unacceptable and inexcusable jokes
at my expense are part of the job but a
joke about jada's medical condition was
too much for me to bear and i reacted
emotionally now one of the big things
that's come out around the discussion
involving the altercation is jada's
medical condition alopecia we still
don't know if rock knew about this and a
lot of people have said that she's been
very open about it i don't think it's as
widely known as people think it is i
certainly didn't know about it and i
doubt that rock did too which is why he
didn't feel bad at dropping jokes on it
jada looks good like that and i think
that the fact that she has her head out
proudly makes most people just assume
it's a choice rather than a disease now
i sign and feel ignorant saying that and
i did have a follower reach out to me
discuss why this goes just beyond being
a bald joke i've blurred their name out
as i don't want people arguing with them
and have spoken to them privately about
the whole situation but basically they
came at it from the standpoint that i
shouldn't really talk about it because
there's nuances in the joke that i don't
really understand they then discussed
how in america black people's hair
especially women's is viewed as being
unprofessional in the workplace it then
brought up the crown act which was only
passed recently that allow black people
to wear their hair naturally and it not
be penalized at work for it it brings up
a whole different discussion about how
just having your natural hair can be
considered unprofessional and making a
joke like this at the oscars which is
viewed as the white establishment was a
bad place to drop it it's something i
honestly didn't even consider when
making the last video and with this
being on the world stage i thought it
was a fair game i wasn't even gonna make
this video but then i thought it's
probably worse to cover just the
negative thing and not the positive one
that follows as it looks like i'm
bothered about the views and not the
story itself anyway some stuff to bear
in mind there for the joke by rock again
do i think he considered any of this or
her alopecia no and i think he kind of
even showed that with his follow-up
comment
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's javascript that was a nice one okay
now if he did think he was making fun of
a disease i don't think he would have
said this because yeah just doesn't make
sense to make fun of something that's
bad and then say it was a nice one now
back to smith's apology and he followed
this up by saying i would like to
publicly apologize to you chris i was
out of line and i was wrong i am
embarrassed and my actions were not
indicative of the man i want to be there
is no place for violence in a world of
loving kindness i would also like to
apologize to the academy the producers
of the show all the attendees and
everyone watching around the world i
would like to apologize to the williams
family and my king richard family i
deeply regret that my behavior has
stained what has been an otherwise
gorgeous journey for us all i am a work
in progress sincerely will so yeah i do
think it's a genuine apology even if
some people think it isn't sincere this
is a big blood of smith's reputation and
he's had a number of things over the
last couple of years that people have
weaponized against him a lot of people
have pointed out that he did laugh at
the joke after rock dropped it and it
was only upon seeing jenny's reaction
that he got up i can totally see this
too and i even saw some tweets saying he
should have punched himself in the face
first for laughing which yeah i thought
were funny however thinking about it the
guy was probably just laughing and
saving face at the time before he really
weighed up what it meant again i don't
think he should have got on stage and
did it but i've been in situations where
a joke's crossed the line with me i've
just laughed at it but felt quite
uncomfortable still i think there was a
time and place to talk to rock about
this and smith chose the worst time and
place to do it this is a great example
of why you shouldn't lose your temper in
public as it can cause a lot of issues
all the hard work he's done his entire
life to get to the point he wins best
actor has been whisked away and now
everyone is dunking on him or getting in
arguments in order to defend him there's
no real winners here at all and everyone
comes out looking terrible but from this
conversation has also come one over
whether he should give his award back or
not personally i don't think he should
as it's an award for a performance in a
film that had nothing to do with him
hitting rock i also think that in
general it's been a lot of people given
awards that have done way worse than
this and it's never really been brought
up i think the academy will probably
allow him to keep it but they might hit
a point where they ban him from future
ceremonies they might not even nominate
him for any future awards and we all
know they're adept at snubbing people
however if he continues to deliver then
they could be forced to do it but either
way this is gonna loom lodge over every
awards ceremony that he attends now
again i'm gonna ask you what you think
as i know there's lots of different
opinions on it i'm also gonna ask you to
keep it civil and leave your thoughts in
the comments below now as a thank you
for interacting with the video and
keeping the conversation going you'll be
entered into a prize draw where we're
giving away three copies of spider-man
noah home on the 15th of april all you
have to do is comment below like the
video or dislike it depending on how you
feel on the story and make sure you
subscribe to the channel like i said the
winners will be chosen on the 15th of
april and if you won the last one then
your name is on screen right now if you
want someone else to watch them make
sure you check out our video on the
whole thing which will be linked below
we go over our thoughts discuss
we go over our thoughts discuss our
initial reaction and yeah if you're
interested in this story then go check
it out without the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see in the next one take care
peace